jornada histórica en colombia estamos en
la plaza de bolívar de bogotá donde va a
ser la toma presidencial de gustavo
petro y también la proclamación vice
presidencial de francia markets espera
desde la organización más de 100.000
personas como podemos ver detrás de mí
que vienen de todo el país y también
colectivos que han apoyado ha gustado
petro y francia- márquez como indígenas
o afrodescendientes
una compleja logística nos han dicho
desde cancillería ya que en otras tomas
presidenciales toda la plaza se
utilizaba para los invitados pero en
esta ocasión el gobierno entrante ha
preferido estar cerca de la gente a mi
izquierda están todos los preparativos
de la logística de los invitados que van
a estar acompañados gustavo petro y
francia- márquez por una decena de jefes
de estados también múltiples líderes
internacionales y la que no va a estar
finalmente es la espada de bolívar ya
que el presidente iván duque no lo ha
permitido algo que había solicitado
gustavo petro ya que recordemos fue
miembro del grupo m-19 que en 1974 robo
a esta espada lo he dicho día histórico
aquí en colombia para dar entrada y
bienvenida al primer gobierno de
izquierda de la historia de colombia